il y a un passage que j'aimerais partager avec
vous
chaque homme doit être soumis aux autorités gouvernementales
car il n'y a pas d'autorité sauf du pays de
Dieu
le chemin de la réhabilitation commence par l'
acceptation il suffit de concevoir une confession
non
je ne suis pas coupable d'avoir tué ma femme
ils '  Je suis condamné à perpétuité et
je suis innocent. La
première infraction est de 90 jours.
C'est toi que
tu crois aux
fantômes.  t comme le logement séparé
change les gens
tu viens de gagner 90 jours de plus
président
tu n'as pas l'air si bien tu ne peux pas m'empêcher
de déposer ma pilule
plutôt gentille
elle essaie de tourner mon esprit contre moi
tout ce qu'elle a à faire est  gardez-nous ici
la chaussure fait tout le travail car
ouais
je vous parle des
gens comme vous
ne méritez pas de seconde chance
je ne l'ai pas fait
non